chutki this sleepy hamlet doesn't just
look like a lost paradise the remote
village located in a tiger reserve is
not connected to the electricity grid
cutting off 600 residents from the
developed world most people here are
farmers they still follow a traditional
way of life but things are changing for
the first time
Chalky's residents have access to
electricity provided by this 30 kilowatt
solar power plant set up earlier this
year it's part of a green technology
project the brainchild of social
entrepreneur
Ashok das we have given them 200 watts
he's partnered with local authorities to
create India's first smart village in
Odisha a shopes company has developed a
smart nano grid technology that allows
the villages entire electrical
infrastructure to be monitored remotely
by the company's staff meters and
sensors collect data on energy
consumption making it easy to remotely
manage supply and demand villagers pay
tariffs based on how much energy they
use the company has also trained local
youth from the village to monitor the
system and detect any faults or
overloading they can even carry out
basic repairs on the spot ensuring the
equipment is well maintained and running
smoothly
Ashok says the model can be a
game-changer by doing smart micro grid
what we are creating we are creating a
basic infrastructure we are creating a
catalytic infrastructure on which many
services will ride irrigation will write
agricultural production will write food
processing can be done cold storage can
be done Health Services will come
telling education services will come all
of these together provide the
development for the village many in the
village are sensing new opportunities
Shrikant cadaver recently bought a
photocopying machine and printer in a
makeshift office he makes copies of ID
cards and land deeds for his customers
as well as takes passport size photos
it's a crucial service in rural India
we're citizens need those documents to
apply for government loans and open bank
accounts hot-bod help myalgia earlier
people had to travel 50 kilometers to
the nearest town to get the documents
photocopy so I thought now that we have
reliable electricity
why don't I provide the services right
here it saves villagers time and money
and I supplement my own income existing
businesses too are seeing the benefits
of uninterrupted access to power as
night falls many can continue to operate
street vendor Prabhakar pristine also
runs a grocery store he now plans to
invest in a fridge and offer cold drinks
to his customers since we have
electricity my business is definitely
improved my shop can stay open till late
in the night
I get more customers for most villagers
the biggest changes since electricity
arrived are simple street lights
provides safety from wild animals a
priority in this tiger reserve a few
households have now got television sets
providing entertainment and drawing a
large young audience tonight some even
get to attend a coaching class in the
village and to homework in the evening
power that empowers there are now plans
to replicate short Ches smart village
model in other Indian states